[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT LEONARD: Welcome,
everybody, this afternoon
to Cloud Billing.
We're going to be talking a
little bit about best practices
for financial governance.
Before we get started,
this is a panel.
It's open Q&A, so
we'll be using Dory.
As you can see, the
instructions are
here and how to ask
questions through the Dory.
So please feel free
to fire away and we'll
try to get your questions
answered as we go through.
I'm going to start with
introducing myself.
My name is Matt Leonard.
I'm the Product Manager
in the Cloud Billing
team with Google Cloud.
I'm going to turn it
over to our panelists
here so they can introduce
themselves and tell you
a little about what
they manage on GCP.
LUKAS KARLSSON: Hi,
I am Lukas Karlsson.
I'm the Cloud
Architect at the Broad
Institute of MIT and Harvard.
We're a genomics research center
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
And we do a lot of
government-funded research
on Google Cloud.
We use an enormous amount
of Google Cloud Storage
in the tens of petabytes.
And we have a very
interesting model,
where we charge back
internally to our grants.
So we have, literally,
hundreds of billing accounts
within the organization, which
makes it very interesting.
SHASHANK JOSHI: Hi.
My name is Shashank Joshi.
I am a specialist leader as part
of Deloitte's cloud engineering
group.
I work with many
of our customers
on their cloud
transformation journey,
focusing mostly on cost
management, governance,
and automation.
CHRIS HOOVER: Hey, everybody.
I'm Chris Hoover.
I work at Etsy.
I look after the team
of business program
managers, finance, legal,
PR, those sorts of things.
We're about one year
into a two-year migration
to Google Cloud.
So we're learning
lots of things.
So far, we've moved our web
platform, APIs, mobile apps.
But still in progress with
search learning, data science,
those things, and still
learning about those things.
DALE HOPKINS: My
name is Dale Hopkins
and I'm the CTO of
Vendasta Technologies.
We're a software company up
in Saskatoon, Saskatchewan.
That's middle of Canada.
And what we do is
we basically help
professionals that sell
services to small business,
augment those services
with software.
And so we've got about
115,000 small businesses
that use our professionals
to purchase software.
And we use pretty
much all of GCP,
except for the genomics API.
Hasn't come in handy yet.
MATT LEONARD: Excellent.
All right.
Well, thanks folks.
We'll dive straight
into a question.
Lukas, what would you
say is the hottest
thing that you have
to manage, in terms
of managing your GCP cost?
LUKAS KARLSSON:
Well, as I mentioned,
we have a large number of
different billing accounts.
So when we get our
bill each month,
we have to sort of split
it up and charge back
to 300 different internal cost
objects, which each represent
a different government grant.
And that whole process can
be pretty tedious for us.
We have the problem
where grants roll over.
A given grant might last
for a year or three,
and then it will stop.
And in order to
continue doing work,
you have to have another
funding source to do it.
So there's a lot
of moving projects
between different
billing accounts,
and tracking all of that
stuff is a big pain.
And I would say, on top of
all that, the biggest thing
is trying to control costs
to make sure that users don't
spend more than they intend.
For us, that's a bigger deal
than your average organization,
because if the grant
you have only provides,
let's say, $10,000 of
compute service resources
and you spend more than
that, the grant is not
going to pay for it.
So we just have to pay
for it out of other funds,
and that's really
frustrating when
you can't do work you plan
to do because somebody
made a little mistake
in their cloud account.
MATT LEONARD: Absolutely.
Chris, would you like to take
it from a different perspective,
from Etsy?
CHRIS HOOVER: Yeah.
Sorry, I had trouble
hearing the question.
Could you repeat it, please?
MATT LEONARD: Sure.
What's the hardest thing
about managing your GCP cost?
CHRIS HOOVER: Yeah.
For us, I think it's just
kind of a change in mindset.
We come from a co-location
facility on bare metal.
Resources and
consumption of them
work way differently there.
The interaction between
us and our finance teams
is a little bit different.
I think there's a
lot to be learned,
in terms of how you
clarify assumptions
and levels of precision for
how we forecast together,
how we develop the tooling
together to make sure
that we're anticipating
costs with seasonality,
those sorts of things.
So for us, it's kind of
learning new muscle memories
in our processes between
different organizations
to make them run more smoothly.
MATT LEONARD: Well,
that about covers it.
So Shashank, from
your perspective
with managing
customers and partners
and helping with the
migration to the cloud,
where do you see the
opportunity for them
to add better controls
in their environment?
SHASHANK JOSHI: Absolutely.
I think the first
thing is no-brainer,
that everybody should
enable their billing
export in BigQuery, and you
should do that on day one.
That definitely is one of the
learnings and the opportunity
that everybody
should be taking up.
Second thing is there
is enormous amount
of data and information there.
So the more your team get
familiar with the data
and analyzes the data,
the more insights
you can draw from
your billing export.
But I think one of the hardest
challenges that organizations
face is billing
is just one piece
of their entire IT organization.
So how to overlay their
architecture onto GCP,
billing export.
That's the important piece.
Because as Lukas
just mentioned, how
will you apportion or
attribute some of the costs
to different teams?
That's the hardest thing to do.
And you can do it using,
for example, labels.
And that gets you to define the
strategy beforehand, and not
just for today and not
just for near future,
but even for six months,
one year down the line.
Because it's really hard to
change the label strategy
once you decided
and going into that.
So some of those lessons
and the opportunities,
in terms of deciding
that early, I
would conclude with one point.
That one is not
every organization
recognizes the importance
of cost management early on.
So there are so many
things that were
able, the foundation,
automation,
this tool, that tool.
But it's really
important to understand
the importance of
cost management
and think about it very early
in your cloud transformation
journey.
MATT LEONARD: Great.
I mean, that's a
good point, though,
as you think about
your cost management
and how you organize your costs.
Dale, how's Vendasta approached
organizing their costs
within the cloud?
DALE HOPKINS: So one of the
things that we have is--
I mean, we may take a little
bit different approach,
but one of the
things we like to do
is basically monitor
and alert on billing,
as opposed to actually setting
hard limits and things.
For us, making sure that the
teams actually have a lot more
say and more understanding
of their actual cost
is a really important
part to getting developers
to actually understand
the cost implications
of the changes they're making.
So I mean, really, for us,
it's a big part of the change,
is actually providing that data.
And I think in a lot of
organizations, the teams
actually writing the
code don't understand
what it costs to operate
that code that they shipped.
And so for us, it's actually
a really useful input to them,
in terms of determining
when to refactor
and when to put more
effort into the code.
I mean, cost is a really great
metric to help you with that.
MATT LEONARD: Yeah.
It's a great point, actually.
And so I'm going to stay
with you for a second.
So what keeps you up at night
when you think about that?
DALE HOPKINS: I guess,
for me, the stuff that
keeps you up at night on cloud
is the opposite stuff than when
you have an on-prem workload.
Your on-prem
workload, I think, is
that you're concerned
that there's
going to be a huge surge
in load and you're not
going to be able to
serve your customers.
The concern we have
is that you're going
to have a huge surge in load.
You're going to serve all
your customers just fine,
you're just not going to
have any money at the end.
And so that's the thing,
especially with some of the--
I mean, it's maybe the
double-edged sword of something
like an App Engine,
or a Pub/Sub,
or one of these services that
basically scales to infinity.
That's awesome, but I mean, as
long as that's what you wanted.
MATT LEONARD: Excellent.
Well, I see Lukas
chuckling away here,
and I'm going to put this
one back on him as well.
Because last year, Lukas
and I talked about,
how do you build better
financial governance controls
for your environment?
And Lukas talked
about it for an hour,
which was great,
because it meant
nobody had to listen to me.
So Lukas?
LUKAS KARLSSON:
So first, I'll say
that what keeps
us awake at night
is the idea that
someone might have
spent $100,000 in the cloud
while we were sleeping.
And we had one incident on
another public cloud where
one of our users,
either intentionally
or unintentionally, spent
$100,000 that they did not
have.
And as I alluded to,
that meant we just
had to pay the vendor from
another bucket of money that
was not intended
for that purpose.
So that incident,
that one incident,
that happened several
years ago entirely
changed how everyone
at the Broad
thought about the
cloud and billing,
and created a lot of
fear and uncertainty
about what we might do,
eventually, in the cloud.
And so for us, it's been
really important to be
able to automate
all of these tasks.
The idea of being able to
get notifications and email
from 300 billing accounts and
process all those notifications
and actually do something
appropriate to respond to them
is really challenging.
So for us, automating
that has been key.
And last year,
Matt's team released
a feature, which I would say is
the second most important thing
you should enable in your
billing account after you get
started, which is to have
a budget, or many budgets,
that publish their
notifications to Pub/Sub.
When you do that, you
can build something
like a Cloud Function that will
receive those notifications
and take potentially appropriate
action on them, which
means that I don't have to read
every email that comes from all
these billing accounts and
decide what should be done.
I can write a Cloud
Function that can do that.
So with 300 or so
billing accounts,
we get like, 1,000 notifications
an hour from the billing
accounts.
And each time that
notification kicks off,
it kicks off a Cloud Function,
which updates a database, so
that we have a
single screen where
we can see the status of all
300 billing accounts at once,
instead of having
to click through
to 300 billing account
consoles, which is not
something I would ever do.
And then in addition,
we added some logic,
where we could put some hard
thresholds in place that we
don't want to ever pass.
And if one of these budgets
passes that threshold,
it can automatically
take an action.
And so the example that we
showed in our talk last year
was three levels
of response, one
being notify someone, maybe
in Slack, or pager duty,
or something like that.
Another bigger hammer is to
identify all the VMs that
are currently running in that
billing account and stop them.
This, for us, is a nice medium,
where we don't lose any data,
but we do, basically, stop
a majority of the spend.
So if we did have this
huge influx of spend,
it allows us to really shut
that down fairly quickly.
And then if you hit
another threshold that
makes you very
uncomfortable, you
can do something like
just turn the billing off
on the projects and
they all stop working,
but you do not spend more money.
So for the engineering folks,
we don't really like that.
But for the folks in procurement
and in sponsored research,
who are managing the grants,
they absolutely love that.
They want to know for sure
that if you were allowed
to spend $10,000
and you hit $10,000,
that you have not spent a
single dollar more than that.
And so implementing that
has certainly helped us
manage that process.
MATT LEONARD: So
that's a great segue.
So Shashank, you work
with a lot of customers
and advise them on how to set up
and organize themselves on GCP.
What kind of best
practices do you recommend?
SHASHANK JOSHI: Sure.
I touched up on that.
The first thing is
that understanding
the importance of cost
management solution in place,
and thinking about
it beforehand, not
as afterthought.
So while you're building
your platform or foundation,
at the same time,
or even before that,
you should be thinking
about your billing solution,
billing analysis solution.
That's the first
thing I would say,
because not many
organizations think like that.
The second best practice
we say is, of course,
user billing export.
The other features
are really good,
in terms of billing reports
and quartiles and alerts.
Those are really good.
But if you need
more insights, you
need to use billing
export, BigQuery,
and analyze that yourself.
Of course, you
can start smaller.
The other best practice we
say is it's like no-brainer,
in terms of don't do all the
required analysis beforehand.
I want to build this
many dashboards.
Don't start like that.
Start with initial dashboards.
Start in a [INAUDIBLE] fashion.
When you start creating
dashboards and reports
and show it to stakeholders,
more and more stakeholders
will buy into your
initiative, and they'll
give you more suggestions,
and you improve on that.
And that's how we have
operated with retail customers
with that.
For example, we started creating
new dashboard every two weeks.
And it can be a minor
improvement on the earlier
dashboard, but that really
helped get excitement
among the people, the
consumers of the dashboards.
And that really
led to that option
into that and the
importance of that.
And I would say
final best practice,
in terms of transparency
and visibility,
what we say is every cloud
transformation should
start with some kind
of a business plan.
And if you don't have that,
if you don't start with that,
now is the time to do it.
Because you need to have
what milestones, initiatives.
You need to break
down all of that
into the minor level details.
And then have a solution,
which can show you, hey,
your budget for this application
was this much for this month,
and where are you
vis-á-vis that?
Because what we have seen
is overall in one example.
So at a one quarter milestone,
overall, the organization,
was under the budget,
but they spent much more
on initiative 1
versus initiative 2.
So even though overall
system looks good,
but you may be
overspending on something
and less spending
on something else.
So it's very important
to go to granular level.
To do a business case,
go to a granular level.
And I would say in
best case scenario
is what we have seen
is they've gone all
the way to individual
applications
and individual environments
in that applications.
So you should know
what I'm supposed
to spend on this application on
dev environment in this month.
So that granular level
is very important.
MATT LEONARD: It's a
great point, actually.
So as you stop to think about
how you're organizing your cost
and driving that budget
down to that granular level,
you start to introduce a
bit of a planning problem.
Chris, I know at Etsy,
you guys have spent a bit
of time thinking about this.
Do you want to talk a
little bit about how
Etsy thinks about budgeting
and planning for the business?
CHRIS HOOVER: Sure, absolutely.
It looks different for
different cadences,
different frequencies,
as you'd imagine,
with our finance cycles.
So annually, we kick
off in about Q4.
So to think about all
of the roadmap items
for our architecture,
all of the things
that engineering wants
to get done, and look
at the consumption
that comes with those.
And then as we march
on throughout the year,
in the typical Agile
fashion, we innovate,
we adapt, and take a
few curves in the road.
And I think the key
there is transparency.
Early notification
of your finance teams
will definitely
help them and build
confidence and trust
in your relationship
with them over time.
It will also, even
implicitly, strengthen
the mutual understanding
of the error
margins in those forecasts.
As you go further
and further on,
you get a feel for how each
other treats the numbers
and what level of
precision we're
able to get to at each point
in our maturity in the cloud.
For us, particularly
because we're mid-migration,
the types of things we're
working on evolves quickly
over time.
And so the type of system
or tool that we're using
and the team using
that uses those things
is a very different
use case in problems
to solve, depending on where
it is in the engineering
organization.
So how we manage
cost in search is
very different from how we
measure and manage costs
for a web platform.
And so educating finance
on how these problems need
to be solved independently
and uniquely is also
a big part of the process.
MATT LEONARD: So
that's a great point.
So Dale, Vendasta has got a
pretty mature offering now,
on top of Google Cloud.
And last year, you
talked a little bit
about how you drive
accountability and visibility
in teams.
Do you want to talk a
little bit about some
of what you've learned from
how you drive visibility
down to your engineering teams?
DALE HOPKINS: One of the
things we found really useful
is the data export,
and that particularly
helps us because you don't
have to assign billing level
permissions to the teams to
have these sort of things,
but you can provide them
the data scope down to what
they're interested in.
And so for us, I mean, just
like so many other things
in your organization, as
soon as you make it visible,
all of a sudden improvements
start to happen.
And so for us, just a big
part of that culture was like,
hey guys, here's your data.
And all of a sudden, that starts
to actually impact behavior.
You don't even
have to tell people
what a good number
or a bad number is.
If you just show them a number
and explain how that relates
and that they affect that, that
made a really big difference
for us, in terms of cost.
And then one of the other
things we found that was helpful
was actually doing a
layer of this week's cost
versus last week's costs.
Because you're
going to find that
it's pretty hard to
compare today to yesterday.
Because for us, specifically, we
got a lot of small businesses.
And if today's Saturday
and yesterday was Friday,
it's not a good comparison
because it just turns out
that people tend to
do different things
on different days like that.
And especially
weekly and monthly
overlays help the team, so
that not just presenting them,
here's a number, but
here's a chart over time.
And if it's up or down
a little bit, that's OK.
But if it's way off, it
kind of gives teams the idea
that they should
look at something.
MATT LEONARD: Great.
This idea of seasonality, from
day-to-day or month to month,
this is obviously something
that Etsy deals with a Q4 peak.
How does Etsy think about
seasonal fluctuations?
CHRIS HOOVER: We've only got one
partial season under our belts,
but I'll speak from that.
I think we've learned a lot
just in that short period.
We found it really
helpful to look back
at historical periods,
even in the data center,
and see how seasonality has
impacted our consumption.
And I would totally agree
that the micro aspect of that,
the day-to-day, the
weekdays, is a big part,
and you want to look at how
that compounds with larger macro
seasonality, from annual
holidays to months of the year,
and everything in between.
Another great conversation to
have with your finance teams
is around what they
forecast for the next season
and melding that with your
consumption estimates,
and therefore, your
cost estimates.
That's a very healthy
and helpful conversation
to have with finance,
to marry the consumption
side and the forecasted
seasonality side,
and have that be
informed by what you've
seen in previous
seasonality at all
of those levels of granularity.
I'll also say that that also
varies by system or product.
So the economies of
scale will definitely
vary based on which GCP
products you're using
and which type of your
infrastructure you're using.
So as an example, with visits
to our website, they may double,
but our consumption of compute
will far less than double,
which is good news, but we
want to be able to forecast
with that good news in advance.
MATT LEONARD: Great.
I'm going to pass it over
to Lukas for a second.
Lukas, you manage something
like 6,000 projects, 300 billing
accounts.
That's a fairly
distributed architecture,
and you've got, obviously,
some important stakeholders
in your planning process from
your accounting and finance
folks, down to your researchers.
How do you manage across
a distributed group
like that in order to
get a plan so that you
can build these budgets?
LUKAS KARLSSON:
First, I just want
to correct the number
that you mentioned there.
I think we're at
25,000 projects now.
MATT LEONARD: My bad.
LUKAS KARLSSON: Last
year, it was 10,000,
so there's been a lot
of growth since then.
So we have a pretty tight
onboarding process for cloud.
We use the same process for
all of the public clouds
that we support currently.
As I mentioned, most of our work
is funded by government grants.
And so internally,
each of those grants
has a seven digit number that
we use as a cost identifier.
We call it a cost object.
And so that's what
people use to buy things,
whether their cloud
services, or supplies,
or whatever they need
for their science.
So users who have funding
and want to use the cloud
have to basically
submit a request
through a process
with procurement,
where they say, hey,
I have this funding
and I want to use
it on the cloud.
And if we know,
based on the number,
that it's an administrative
funding source--
like my IT budget
is an admin budget,
it's not funded by a grant--
then it mostly
just gets approved.
The person who's
making the request
is the authority on
that cost object,
and they can decide
how much to spend.
But if it's funded by
a government grant,
then the people who manage
the sponsor research funding
have to be involved.
They have to check the
grant and make sure
that it has enough
funding to support what
the group is intending to do.
And then they also
have to check the grant
and make sure it actually
allows you to spend money
on the cloud.
So all of that has to
happen before we even
give them access.
And then once
everything is approved,
we basically create
a new billing account
for that particular cost object
and give the user billing
account administrator.
And now, they own
that billing account,
and they're responsible
for whatever happens in it.
They can delegate
permissions to people
within their team to create
projects, if they wish.
Or if they don't have
that level of trust
with the people on
their team, they
may choose to
create the projects
themselves and give
the teammates access.
Another common model
is users in our company
are allowed to
create projects all
they want, they're just
not allowed to add billing,
unless they're a billing
account administrator.
So people on your team
can create projects
and then they can give
you a sufficient level
of access to their project that
you can enable billing on it
for them.
And we have literally all
of these different models
in place at the Broad.
And in addition, we
have some situations
where projects that we own
that are in our organization
are being funded by someone
else's billing account.
And we have situations
where projects
that are owned by an
external organization
are being funded by one
of our billing account.
So basically, every
scenario you could imagine,
we have currently.
But that process is what
we use, whether people
are trying to get onboard
with Google or any
of the other public clouds.
MATT LEONARD: Excellent.
All right, Shashank, you
advise a lot of customers.
How do you start estimating
costs for a new project,
like ballpark figures?
What does that look like?
SHASHANK JOSHI: Sorry.
Say that again.
MATT LEONARD: So a customer
comes to you and say,
hey, we'd like to move a
workload into Google Cloud
and we're planning to build
something completely new
from scratch.
How do you even go about
ballparking that budget
estimate?
And what tools, I guess, are
available to you to do that?
SHASHANK JOSHI: That's
a really good point.
And the best practice we
follow is during the migration
analysis, we do the billing
view of that as well.
So do the billing review very
early in your design cycle.
So that's a really good point.
If you're not doing
that, it should
be part of your governance.
When you are planning for
a migration application,
you should see how the
cost of that would be.
Having said that, what we
have done to estimate the cost
was looking at the trends,
looking at the usage,
at the customer.
We actually created
separate calculators,
in terms of unit price.
For example, if you're
using compute instances
at a large scale, you would have
a certain amount of permitted
use discounts, system
use discounts, and some
of the other discounts,
and some percentage
of on demand pricing.
So your unit price
turns out to be
for a compute, which is
vastly different from what
you see on the website.
So for all the services
that you're consuming,
you should have
some kind of a unit
price for your
organization worked out.
That's not 100% accurate,
but that's close there.
And use those unit prices to
estimate your ballpark figure
for your consumption.
So if it's, let's say a
three-tier application,
you can say, how many
compute instances?
How much data?
How much egress?
So you know the unit
price for each service
and you can estimate the
price for that application.
But yeah, and I think
the interesting anecdote
that me and Matt discussed
before was the unit price is
not constant all the time.
So coming back to the
seasonality question,
so I was working
on the retailers.
And when you see this seasonal
Black Friday or Thanksgiving
weekend, the spike
is much higher.
And your committed
users, these commitments
are for a year or three years.
You cannot make a
commitment for one month.
So how do you manage that?
And during that peak
cycle, on-demand use
is going to go up significantly.
So in your makeup of
compute instances,
the ratio of on demand
is going to increase,
and that comes at
a higher price.
So your unit price,
during the peak,
is higher than your
regular unit price.
So when you estimate for,
let's say, a peak size,
peak season, you're
not just having
to estimate for the additional
capacity that you want,
but that capacity is maybe
coming at a higher price.
So using that seasonal
variation, also
the unit pricing, that's a
key to estimating the price.
MATT LEONARD: Excellent.
So there's been a number of
questions from the audience.
I'm just going to
try and collate them
together in a single one.
What tools are
you using in order
to organize, and then view,
and then internally chargeback
those costs?
I'm going to ask you, Chris,
as a big corporation that
obviously has many departments
running infrastructure on GCP.
What are you using
to manage this?
CHRIS HOOVER: Sure.
Right now, we're using
the Native Cloud Console.
It's grown a good bit
in the last year or so.
We're seeing some new
functionality come out.
I know the Billing Product
management team at Google
is hard at work and
rolling out new features,
getting visibility into
different types of discounts
within the bill.
So we are anxiously awaiting
more development there.
That's kind of a factor
in how we're developing
our own use of tools.
So let me run through the
list of the rest of the things
that we're currently
using, BigQuery, Data
Studio, and Looker, as well,
for our current dashboards.
Also, in the Agile fashion of
rolling those out incrementally
to kind of suit the
need and show people
and let that data
drive action naturally.
We have kind of a
two-pronged need
here, not just for billing,
but also for our sustainability
goals.
We're very interested not
just in cost efficiency,
but also in the efficiencies
of the resources
we use, the energy of the
pull from the environment
and measuring that.
So we have double
motivation at Etsy
to really get the tooling right.
And in this early stage
of our tooling roadmap,
we're kind of
merging and syncing
the paces of that internal
tool development, the use
of the already provided tools,
and understanding where Google
is developing its
own functionality
for future features to get
an idea of what this looks
like in a steady state for us.
I think there's still a
good bit more ahead for us.
MATT LEONARD: And I'll pass
it on to Dale, as well.
Dale, you've built some pretty
cool stuff using DataShare.
How do you share
those costs around
within your organization?
DALE HOPKINS: How many of
you in the audience here,
with a show of hands,
use Data Studio currently
in your organization? 'Cause
it's not nearly as many
as I might have thought.
Data Studio is
actually really great.
It allows you to build
these dashboards.
And so one of the
things we've done
is we've actually put together
Data Studio dashboards
and they share, kind of like
Google Docs, not quite as good,
but sort of similar idea.
And you can actually
put these up
on monitors just in the hall.
And so you can actually,
in a team's room,
have their costs right there.
And so they're
literally confronted
by a chart of their costs
when they walk in the door.
So I mean, it's a
simple tool and it
queries pretty much
anything out of BigQuery,
or any other Google source,
and it's really quite easy.
So I'd encourage you to give it
a shot, because it's really not
as intimidating.
And it makes graphs
that are beautiful,
and I don't make
beautiful graphs,
so that's kind of exciting.
I mean, the other
tool that I think
is everybody's
favorite that nobody
likes to admit they use is
Sheets, which is awesome, too.
Because you can just dump
raw data in there, and that's
something to play with
and figure out beforehand.
But those are the two
tools that we use.
One of them is much
prettier than the other.
MATT LEONARD: For
any of you that
might be feeling
intimidated about DataShare,
I'm just a product manager.
So I was like, I don't
know about this DataShare,
till after watching Dale
build these amazing dashboards
in about seven minutes on
stage at Next last year,
I was like, I'm an expert.
This thing is super easy.
So definitely encourage any
of you to take a look at it.
We're going to take another one.
How much time do
you spend, Lukas,
on managing billing data across
your multi-cloud deployments?
I'm not going to
pick on GCP here.
I'm going to make
it multi-cloud.
LUKAS KARLSSON: Way more
than I ever expected.
I'm a tech guy.
I like to build big scaling
systems in the cloud.
And it turns out that I'm one
of the world's experts on Google
billing now, which is not
ever something I expected
to have happen.
So it's quite a bit of time.
I think you guys
have certainly made
it easier over the last year or
two with all the new features.
We've been a GCP
customer for a long time.
So before the BigQuery
feature existed,
we were manually importing our
CSVs every day into BigQuery
so that we had some
visibility into the data.
And then when you guys
released that feature,
we didn't have to build
that ETL process anymore.
We just turn on the switch.
Before we had access
to Data Studio,
we were already a Tableau shop.
So we put a lot of
effort into building
some really advanced Tableau
reports that do some very
broad specific things.
Like when you have grant
funding and then you
use that grant funding to
pay for a cloud service,
there's an overhead tax
that gets applied to that
as part of your organization.
And so we need to
let our users see
what the full loaded cost
of the cloud is going to be,
not what the actual bill
from Google is going to be,
because it's not the same.
So we have all of those
tools built into Tableau.
And then when Data
Studio came out,
we have built a bunch of
visualizations in Data Studio.
Many of those have actually
been replaced by the features
that you guys have
built into the console.
So I think now, the thing
I use the most, by far, is
the reports in the
console, absolutely.
And these other tools,
sometimes we actually
have to take new features
that you guys have brought,
like the recent release
of the invoice month.
And we're now introducing those
features into the Data Studio,
into the Tableau tools
that we use as well.
But between me and
Stuart in procurement,
we spend many, many hours
a month dealing with this.
I mean, just the time that
he spends taking the bill
and charging back to 300
different internal cost
objects, 30 or 40
of which will have
expired since the last month.
So for each of those,
he has to go figure
out what the new
funding source is,
and it's such a huge burden.
So we're constantly
working on ways
to automate that,
building App Engine apps
that he uses to
manage the accounts,
and giving him more reports
in Data Studio, and so forth.
MATT LEONARD: Great.
I mean, Chris, you have a
similar type of environment.
Sorry, Shashank.
I'm going to come back
to you in a minute.
You have a similar
type of environment.
How much time is
your organization
spending and dedicated resources
to organizing and charging
back costs?
CHRIS HOOVER: We have
one billing account,
which makes it a little
bit simpler in comparison.
But it is,
nevertheless, complex.
We've been very thankful
in standing by the decision
to hire a dedicated resource
to manage this full-time.
So we have a program manager.
You might find an analyst
to be helpful in spending
full-time focus
and understanding
and forecasting, sort
of as a liaison to all
of your engineering teams, by
products that they're using
and by roadmap type, what
they're doing in Google Cloud.
I think you'll quickly find
that that type of person's time
is consumed on very
meaningful things.
At Etsy, that person--
Danny, he might be here.
Wave to Danny.
He floats between finance and
accounting and engineering,
and speaks very
knowledgeably about all
of these things,
along with Google,
and is kind of a single
library of information
that really helps us
connect these things.
So if you haven't
already, or if you're
in the early stages of
starting on the cloud,
I think, as part of
resource planning,
that people planning
and an analyst
or a program manager to do
these things proactively
is a really smart call.
MATT LEONARD: Thanks.
And we see that quite
a bit, that customers
have somebody who's
dedicated and committed
to what does that cost
management story look
like in the cloud.
I mean, so Shashank, we
got a lot of questions
from the audience today about,
how do we organize the cost?
Obviously, Google has folders.
They have projects.
These are all visible
in the billing data.
But one of things we
haven't really talked about
is labels and label strategy.
How do customers approach
a labeling strategy
for their environment?
SHASHANK JOSHI: Absolutely.
I think this is, I think,
the most important part
for the larger
organizations, because GCP
exists into a
larger IT ecosystem
for big organizations.
So there are lines
of businesses that
have vice presidents, department
heads, and application owners.
So there is a big organization
structure outside of GCP.
So how will you impose that?
Because nobody wants to
see overall GCP cost.
They would want to see,
what is my team's cost?
Or if it is a vice
president, they
would want to see, what
are all the applications
under his line of business?
And how they are doing vis-á-vis
the budget that they have.
So it's very important
how do you do that.
And there are two ways to
do that, as Matt mentioned.
One way, recently announced, I
think comparatively recently,
is you can align your organized
structure with the GCP resource
organization.
And by that, I mean
your folder structure.
So you can have a folder
structure dedicated
to vice president, and
everything related to him
is under that.
And that data flows
into your billing export
with Project Ancestry.
So you can use that field
to identify this project
belongs to this VP.
So this is very
simple to start with.
But you may get into challenges.
Because if there are
projects shared by two VPs,
or there is a project that is
not assigned to any one VP,
or projects moves from
one folder to one other,
there are complications
related to that.
And of course, this is
at the project level.
So what if you want to
go beyond the project?
If you're running, let's
say, different applications
within one project,
how would you
distribute that, or
different environments?
So the best way of doing
that is using labels.
And label strategy, as I said,
you cannot change it often.
You are decided very early
on, and not just for today.
As I said before, you are to
do it for three months or six
months down the line as well.
Because data hardware
change labels
know when you are
already in process.
And I would say some examples
of that using, for example,
it can be a vice
president or department.
It can be by application.
It can be by environment.
And I've seen uses, where
even the operations team uses
the labels, for example,
for batching cycles,
and all of that.
So it's not only
billing related,
but it's really significant,
in terms of billing.
And all of these label data
flows into your GCP export,
billing export, in BigQuery.
And again, there are two labels.
There are project labels.
There are resource labels.
So you can even
drill down further.
The opportunities are immense,
but it's very complex as well.
Because initially, we struggled.
I remember two years
ago when labels came,
and we tried to use it
in the very beginning.
It's a nested feel in BigQuery.
And when we applied the sum of
everything and all of our costs
went up five times, and
everybody was shocked.
Then we realized.
I would say, it's
really important
that your team is familiar
with the export schema.
And the number of
services that are launched
so frequently by Google
Cloud, the schema
is changing all the time.
For example, this folder budget
ancestry feature was not there
last year, I believe.
So a lot of new features
are coming into export,
so it's very important that
your team is familiar and adapt
to really change the schema.
MATT LEONARD: Yeah, thanks.
There's lots of props
that, for all the features
that we're launching, we are
trying to improve things.
For those of you who
didn't catch it earlier,
Target did a presentation
earlier today
where they talked about
their label strategy and some
of the mistakes that
they made, not ensuring
that they had consistent
label strategy
across their organization
early on, and then
in terms of governance.
So if you didn't see that, it
will be available on YouTube
after Next.
But they talk about how they
use [INAUDIBLE] in order
to govern their
environment and make sure
that their resources
are labeled consistently
across their environment.
So it's a great session.
SHASHANK JOSHI: Yeah.
I think one point,
as well on this one,
where we decided
to label strategy,
we also had a labeling
compliance dashboard.
So we built a dashboard on
how compliant every project
is on labels.
So if you're missing
a label, we'll
show that as like you
missed the compliance.
MATT LEONARD: Yeah.
And so what we're working on
some tools to help with that,
but definitely check
out the Target session.
It's very useful.
Now, the top upvoted
question here from the Dory
is actually, how do I
reduce my GCP costs?
Who'd like to take
that one first?
Excellent.
DALE HOPKINS: There's
lots of different ways
to reduce your costs.
I guess this kind of depends
on your particular story
and your application.
So some of the ways
that we've done things
is we started on
GCP a long time ago,
and some of the cost model,
we're on Python 2-7 App Engine.
Migrating to a more
modern stack can often
change the efficiency,
usage as memor, and CPU,
and also the cost model on
some of the GKE resources
being lower than those
of App Engine standard.
That's one way that, for
us, that's our primary cost
reduction model, is
actually moving things
from App Engine standard
into a more modern runtime.
I mean, App Engine standard
has modern runtimes, but not
the one that we use.
One of the other ways is,
obviously, sitting down,
look at your GCP bill.
And if you are a continuous
user, and at the end of it,
you see a sustained
use discount,
I mean, that's an
opportunity right there
to do a committed discount,
if that's something
that you actually think.
So I mean, obviously,
don't do that if you
have a ton of
seasonal fluctuation,
but that's something that
we've also done to save cost.
Those are the big ones for us.
MATT LEONARD: I'm going
to let everybody take
this one, Chris, take it away.
CHRIS HOOVER:
Preemptibles might be
another one along
very similar lines,
depending on the workloads.
CUDs would be on one
end of the spectrum,
preemptibles would
be on the other,
but both are really high
cost savings off the list.
Really depends on what
products you're using.
I mean, if you're
heavy storage users,
you should weigh Nearline
versus Coldline and all
the other storage options
with what you actually need.
I think autoscaling
is also a great thing
to look into, across the board.
Some things are a
little bit more complex,
and you might want to form a
short-term squad, so to speak,
of cross-functional team members
from different engineering
teams to look into what
could non-destructively
create some efficiencies.
There's a little
bit of research that
could go a long
way, potentially,
in finding things
that you could just
use in a slightly
different way but still get
the same benefits
from that consumption.
SHASHANK JOSHI: Sure.
And we recommend to approach
this in multiple ways.
One part of
governance is biweekly
or weekly, we have
cost optimization
reports, dashboards.
And the way we look
at that is everybody
looks at the top
five cost drivers.
So if Compute Engine was higher
for you than your estimation,
you drill down.
So that's where the
dashboard come in.
So if compute was high,
why it was higher?
So in many cases, we realized
licensing cost was higher.
So is there a way you
can optimize that,
using your own licensing.
And sometimes your storage
costs were higher for disks.
That's where another
good feature comes in.
You have to marry your billing
data with the platform data.
So in one case, we had a lot
of custom GCP Python scripts
just going around and finding
how many orphan disks that you
have, the disks which are
not connected to any server
and nobody knows
that they exist.
So that cost gets
added to your thing.
So you're to marry your billing
export with the platform data,
so you get platform data
[INAUDIBLE] into that.
And finally, I would say you
have to make the billing review
as part of your design process.
So you are to push the billing
related thing very early
into your design cycle.
I would say 99% of the
times, it's afterthought.
They launch the application,
migrate the application.
They do their cheers
and all of that,
but then a month later, they
see the cost has gone higher.
So best practice is to really
do the review much earlier on.
Do the optimization
using autoscaling,
or any other features
of optimization
early on before you launch
an application on the cloud.
LUKAS KARLSSON: So let's see.
I would say Dale hit on
probably the best thing to do
is just really make it all
visible to the people who
are dealing with it.
So if they users who are doing
cloud don't look at their bill
and don't know what's
getting spent in there,
the likelihood
that they're going
to change their behavior to
reduce cost is absolutely no.
So making it as visible as
possible and as easy for them
to understand how their behavior
is affecting the costs is huge.
Also, I would also
reiterate that educating
people on the different
services and how they're charged
is really key.
If someone deployed an App
Engine app on App Engine
Flexible because that was
their preference at the time,
and they don't realize
that app runs 24/7,
whereas an App Engine
in standard app
only runs when it's needed, I
mean, that's a huge difference.
It can be the difference
between something
that you pay every month
for and something that
maybe doesn't cost anything.
Similarly, if people are used
to spinning up SQL databases
and they have them
running all the time
and they don't know
about BigQuery,
and that they might be able to
store more data in BigQuery,
get better performance,
and at lower cost,
I think that's huge, too.
So we really need
to educate people
on the features of the platform
and where the cost savings are.
And then I would also
mention about labels.
We've done a lot with labels.
We started out just using
labels to do what we do now
with billing accounts,
to know which cost object
a certain thing would bill to.
And then the next
level of that was,
how does my dev environment
cost differently than my prod
environment, which labels
are very useful for.
But in our environment, a lot
of our analysis in the cloud
runs in a workflow
format, where you
have many steps of
a workflow occurring
to get a single job done.
And we are actually
able to put labels
on each of the
steps of a workflow,
so that even though you might
know the cost of that analysis,
you also know the cost of
each step of the analysis.
So the team that's developing
that particular part,
if their thing is the most
expensive part of the process,
they're very
incentivized to improve
the performance of their
steps so that it reduces cost.
And the labels, let that be
very, very visible so everyone
can see it and take action.
MATT LEONARD: Great.
This is great recommendations.
It sounds like, essentially,
driving visibility
and accountability is key.
Sounds like there's a
little bit of tooling,
a little bit of pricing
optimization, that's
available through committed
use discounts, which is great.
How many of you are using GKE
in order to manage your cost?
Anyone?
All right, Dale, take this one.
So it's one of the
questions that we got,
is if I am using GKE, how do
I organize my costs in order
to understand to be able
to charge back by namespace
those costs to the
internal departments?
DALE HOPKINS: Yeah, so
for a background here,
Lukas talks about
having 25,000 projects.
I have one project that accounts
for over 70% of my billing.
So actually diving
into that project
and understanding a
lot more about what's
happening in that project
is really important to me.
And a significant
portion of that cost
comes into Kubernetes.
And so having the billing
aware, Kubernetes aware,
because things like
namespaces are actually
a really relevant
thing, in terms
of breaking down those costs.
And then actually
monitoring those costs
are important, because
people may find--
I mean, we talked about
that their dev environment,
or their demo environment is
absolutely crushing something
and they forgot that
they're not using that.
And those are important
to break down,
especially an
environment where--
I mean, we're a
modestly sized company
and we've got well over
200 microservices running
at any one time in our
Kubernetes cluster.
And so all it takes is
for one of those services
to be out of whack.
And it maybe doesn't present
itself at the project level,
but if you were looking
each one of them,
you can actually see that.
So that's a very helpful thing
that we've been looking at.
MATT LEONARD: Excellent.
And I apologize, we are
running out of time.
So some of the
other questions that
have been asked in the Dory,
we'll try to answer offline.
Just really quickly,
Dale, any closing thoughts
for the audience?
Any closing thoughts?
DALE HOPKINS: I just
thought of one other thing.
In terms of a show of
hands, does anybody here
use Spanner or Bigtable?
OK.
We don't have a ton
of people, but I
mean, interestingly
enough, I think
it's Spotify that put out an
open source tool for actually
scaling up and down Bigtable.
And we actually modified
that to work for Spanner,
and that made a
significant difference.
So I think making costs
public and looking
for these kind of things,
because autoscaling
is one of the things that
really does reduce costs.
I means, it's the promise
of the cloud, right?
So my thoughts, make your
costs visible and, I guess,
just look at always
working on it.
CHRIS HOOVER: Maybe one
other slightly tactical thing
that we haven't talked about.
We didn't really talk too
much about networking.
It would be worthwhile to
look at how much your data's
spending within a zone,
but also between zones
and across regions.
Some of that might
be unintentional.
You might be charging
a little bit more
than you expect to there and
may not be getting a benefit.
So just looking at where your
data is traveling across,
systems and regions,
could be worthwhile.
SHASHANK JOSHI: Yeah.
I would like to leave one
point of understanding
the importance of cost
management solution in place.
So if you're not already
thinking about it,
I would want to reiterate.
And another thing, in terms
of we talked about tooling.
In many organizations, you don't
have the choice of coming up
with, for example, Data Studio.
We looked at that
many customers.
But many organizations
already have a tooling
for cost management, because
GCP is not their first cost
component.
They may have other clouds,
private cloud, co-lo,
all of those things.
So you may not have a
choice, in terms of tooling,
but make that choice early on.
Because one example,
one experience we had,
was one of the
retailers, we started off
with the on-prem data storage
using Lstack and Tableau.
Nothing wrong with
that platform, per se,
but the system was
so slow, in terms
of adapting to
Agile methodology,
that we had to switch
back to BigQuery,
and then Tableau in GCP.
So make the tooling
decision also very early on,
thinking not just from
today's requirements,
but what you would
do in coming days.
And lastly, I would say
automate for optimization,
that I forgot to
mention earlier.
That for cost reduction,
we came up with many ideas
for automation.
You can create
environments, like
sandbox, timebox
environments, this environment
is [INAUDIBLE] to
the dev team, but it
will be automatically recycled
in two weeks or three weeks.
So time [INAUDIBLE]
environments are--
For some of the dev teams, which
are using a lot of cost, what
we did for them was
all the dev at once,
all the product labels labeled
as dev would be shut down.
All the instances would be
shut down over the weekend,
or out of the office hours.
So you can use automation
to really optimize
the cost using labels.
MATT LEONARD: All right.
And, Lukas, I'll ask
you to keep it fast,
because we're
running out of time.
LUKAS KARLSSON:
Well, I talk mostly
about how to do things at
scale, so I'll actually just
give a hint to people who have
a very simple billing setup.
Google Bill's on
the calendar month.
So if you set up a budget
that will alert you,
let's say, at 50%, and
if you receive the alert
from that budget and it's
before the 15th of the month,
then that's problematic.
And if it's after the
15th of the month,
you don't need to
worry about it.
MATT LEONARD:
That's a good point.
Thank you, Lukas.
Just closing thoughts.
One of the questions is,
where can I learn more
about cost management?
We have a bunch of sessions
that you can attend.
There's, in fact, 12 sessions
throughout Google Next
this year.
I would recommend you
take that opportunity
to check in some of
those other sessions.
They're going to teach you
about things like Data Studio
and how to set budgets
for your environment.
So please take that opportunity.
We also have a bunch
of other material
on our website that will
point you towards webinars,
and other things, where you
can learn about cost management
tooling.
Thank you all for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]